the handmaid's tale season 4 began
airing on hulu in april 2021 and it
drastically altered the course of hulu's
acclaimed dystopian series
after fighting to bring down gilead from
the inside protagonist
june osborne escapes to canada and is
reunited with her friends
husband luke and baby daughter nicole
but assimilating back into ordinary life
proves incredibly difficult for june
leaving her loved ones and viewers to
wonder
what healing and moving on from gilead
could possibly look like for her
june is still preoccupied with rescuing
her older daughter hannah from gilead's
clutches
and longs for revenge against those who
had directly oppressed her during her
time as a handmaid
particularly the now imprisoned fred and
serena waterford
while the waterford started off the
season at odds they're forced to come
back together to devise their freedom
from canadian authorities
after serena discovers she is somehow
pregnant but their freedom is precarious
and their facade as an ideal gilead
family has been obliterated
more than any other season this
installment of the handmaid's tale
asks how we move forward from times of
intense trauma
how we seek justice and what it means to
heal here's the ending of the handmaid's
tale
season 4 explained i made a promise to
hurt them
the way we heard after narrowly
surviving a gunshot wound at the
beginning of season 4
june makes it to chicago and is brought
to canada by her best friend moira but
as the season explores through june's
journey
and experiences gilead lives within its
victims
even after they escape its borders she
becomes consumed with a desire for
vengeance
emotionally detaching from her loved
ones to plot the waterford's takedown
as a proxy for getting revenge on gilead
as a whole
by the finale when june learns that fred
and serena will likely be freed for
giving the canadian government gilead
intelligence secrets
she takes matters into her own hands and
arranges for fred to be captured and
taken to the no man's land between
canada
and gilead recreating the salvaging june
and several other former handmaids
brutally kill fred in the woods and
leave his body hanging
on the wall however june could face
heartbreaking personal consequences for
her revenge plot and even tells luke
she'll leave after he realizes what
she's done
she has powerful contacts within gilead
like commander lawrence
and her lover nick blaine who could
bring her hannah but her
self-destructive untreated trauma could
prevent her from bringing about
actual change june's need for vengeance
is understandable
but it could lead to horrible
ramifications down the road
it just
i need fred to get what he deserves
although serena and fred are forced to
put up a united front throughout season
four in hopes of escaping canadian
custody and living freely with their son
their relationship gets even more
strained as the series progresses
fred has a renewed interest in serena
now that she's carrying his son
while serena is moved by the pro-gilead
protesters who applaud her
on their way to june's testimony the
waterford's personal conflicts have
always shown how people who directly
work to uphold
patriarchal structures are often hurt by
the very laws and expectations
they helped create this theme comes full
circle in season four as serena faces
the possibility of being separated from
her son at birth
and being turned into a handmaid should
she return to gilead
a dark mirror to serena's violation of
june an attempt to steal baby nicole
as her own fred who hides behind
chivalry and theological goodness to
cover up his spineless misogyny
is ultimately taken down by his own
blindness to women's capabilities
and complexities he easily allows june
to coax him into believing
she still cares for him and is killed
through a gilead ritual
he helped create next season serena will
likely find herself truly
on her own for the first time as she
reckons with the world
she chose for herself and how she
subjugated other women
in the process while june's season 4
character arc shows how unprocessed
trauma can consume you and change your
perception of the world
in major ways her loved ones in canada
spend the season attempting to find new
ways forward
luke moira and emily continue working to
help gilead refugees
enter canada and begin new lives outside
of the theocracy
they're also helping nurture the next
generation as luke and moira
are nicole's primary caregivers and
emily continues reconnecting with her
son oliver
moira also gets a second chance at love
through her burgeoning relationship with
her headstrong co-worker una
meanwhile a recently freed rita grapples
with unlearning
all the behaviors gilead has taught her
such as her automatic tendency to serve
people through cooking and housework
one of the most striking scenes of the
season is her work with a little boy
who was recently freed from gilead but
has no memories of a time before then
and struggles to adjust
jun's friends and family are fighting
for the possibility of a post-gilead
world but the most
well-adjusted characters are still
struggling to accept that such a world
may never truly exist a journey which
will surely continue
next season as the characters grapple
with the new society
they've worked to craft together
i am a citizen of the united states
and i seek asylum
in the country of canada the handmaid's
tale season 4
spent less time in gilead than ever
before but the scene
set there reinforce how precarious the
country's rigid system is
and how this uncertainty affects the
next generation
a new recurring character is esther keys
a 14 year old wife
who hopes to get revenge on the
commanders who have brutally assaulted
her
she's punished and turned into a
handmaid alongside june's friend
janine but aunt lydia is rapidly losing
control over the handmaids who resist
her with a food strike
season 5 could mark a full-on handmade
revolution if things go well
or as well as they can go in gilead the
men left in gilead are also torn between
standing with their rocky new country
and accepting the growing revolution
commander lawrence who was the original
architect of gilead
initially asks for 10 gilead child
refugees
in exchange for hannah later he went
against the grain
and helped her destroy fred and nick
continues working for gilead throughout
the season but seemingly defects
after reuniting with june and their baby
daughter season five is bound to push
the handmaid's tale
characters to the brink even more and
challenge what exactly freedom could
look like in a world of patriarchal
violence
bless it be the fruit check out one of
our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you